vous ne verrez que ses mains pas ses
larmes
deux ans après les faits cette jeune
fille ne s'est toujours pas remise de
son passage au supermarché d'héricourt
un cdi
une grossesse et la voilà convoqué par
son directeur des horaires une fois le
matin je devais revenir l'après-midi
tout pour m'embêter
j'en rêvais l'ami jean charest pousser à
bout les salariés indésirables les faire
partir par tous les moyens y compris les
plus bas c'est cette technique de
management que dénonce aujourd'hui le
procureur celle là même qui a poussé
kevin jusqu'au burn out après 75 heures
sup en quatre mois et un épisode d'une
rare violence
oodrive où il travaillait aurait monté
et nous a dit que cette grève est à
vomir qu'on était dégueulasse on était
des viendrait des ports que l'on pouvait
les chalets dans les jupons haute mer
même à l'échelle et aux prud'hommes qui
n'avaient rien à quatorze
plaintes en 2018
onze autres ce mois ci pour l'avocate
des victimes il faut mettre un terme de
toute urgence aux agissements d'une
direction qu'elle qualifie d' infernale
les victimes sont en telles souffrances
qu'elles finissent par développer des
symptômes psychologiques et physiques se
traduisant par une grande fatigue voire
une dépression leur détresse est telle
que certains ont songé à mettre fin à
leurs jours
simple aléa dans l'exercice du devoir de
direction pour la défense qui dénonce
une coalition malhonnête aux visées très
précises le seul fondement de l'action
judiciaire c'est l'argent qu'on ne
vienne s'il si le fondement avait été le
harcèlement moral
on aurait eu des plaintes qui aurait été
déposée immédiatement ou voir même avant
les licenciements on a attendu de faire
les procédures prud'homales demander des
dommages et intérêts et déposé la
plainte pénale alors je veux bien qu'on
vient de pleurer devant des caméras de
télévision mais faut pas me raconter
d'histoires ce qu'on veut c'est un gros
chèque
un gros chèque que notre victime anonyme
ne touchera pas elle n'a même pas porté
plainte
je pense que l'internât est confronté
je ne sais pas
un jour peut-être en aura-t-elle le
courage pour faire éclater la vérité
[Musique]